Inzwischen sind es schon 51 je oller verdachtsfälle im kongo das erschreckende zum, ersten, mal gab es einen ebola verdachtsfall in einer millionenstadt werden
Ja darüber berichtet das ist eine große. Gefahr aber die weltgesundheitsorganisation reagiert dieses mal deutlich schneller als bei der
Letzten epidemie bei der zwischen 2014. Und 2016. Mehr als 11.000 menschen in westafrika. Starben wird es dieses mal
So weit kommen die. Aktuelle entwicklung bei klicks, um, science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Es ist bereits der neunte ausbruch im kongo von ebola in den. Letzten 40. Jahren, und bisher hält er sich noch in grenzen
Das sind gott sei dank. Noch sehr übersichtliche. Zahlen die da aus dem kongo gemeldet werden bisher 51
Verdachtsfälle, und 27 tote wobei sich die verdachtsfälle während der letzten epidemie fast immer
Alle erhärtet hatten aber dieses mal hat die weltgesundheitsorganisation
Wer wirklich sehr schnell reagiert der generalsekretär der. Whu petrus g3
Jesus war schon vor ort und konnte jetzt auf der jahrestagung der
Whu aus erster hand berichten, er ist sehr besorgt über den patienten in der millionenstadt
Andererseits sieht er die. Whu deutlich besser vorbereitet als noch
2014 am flughafen der millionenstadt werden. Alle ankommenden passagiere auf fieber untersucht. Und im gegensatz zum
Ausbruch 2014 gibt es jetzt endlich, einen impfstoff, er ist zwar. Noch nicht zugelassen wird aber jetzt bereits
Im kongo eingesetzt alle personen die mit erkrankten
Zu tun haben dass in rund 600 werden jetzt kämpft damit wird das risiko eines super verarbeiters deutlich gesenkt das könnte zum
Beispiel eine pflegerin oder ein pfleger sein der. Dann zahlreiche gesunde anstecken würde allerdings ist das alles
Keine, garantie dass der ausbruch wirklich. Kontrolliert werden kann bei der letzten, wm in westafrika was unter anderem
Eine heilerin die zur super verbreitet wurde, und letztlich können ja auch nicht alle reisenden in und aus der stadt kontrolliert werden
So hat die. Aktuelle epidemie. Zwei seiten. Zum. Einen war die weltgesundheitsorganisation. Noch nie
So gut vorbereitet zum anderen gab es aber. Noch nie, einen fall. So früh in einer millionenstadt ist bleibt
Also leider sehr spannend im kongo wenn. Ihr nichts zu holen und zu allen anderen dem verpassen wollt dann endet
Mich bei whatsapp. Und den anderen messengern nur dann verpasst ihr kein video
Ihr wisst ja die abo box bei youtube die ist ja nicht. So zuverlässig dann erfahrt
Ihr von mir vor allen andern vom neuesten video täglich und garantiert einfach hier draufklicken. Und zur begrüßung habe ich ein kleines
Juli, und am besten. Auch meinen schwesterkanal kriegs zum social and media abonnieren da geht's auch hier hin da
Ihr vater das neueste aus der social media welt nicht die
Genau, die glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
Ja mit allen infos. Zur. Aktuellen, ebola epidemie ja ansonsten bis. Dann
bleibt dran